[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey everyone i'm brian wood i'm the pr
manager
here at wolfram uh today i'm here with
danielle mayer
director of communications and outreach
how you doing today danielle
i'm fantastic how are you brian i am
excellent thank you for asking
uh danielle's here to talk a little bit
about remote work and remote learning
um this is a little bit of a different
topic from some of our usual tech talks
uh instead of necessarily talking just
about wolfram technology we're going to
talk about some of the
technology and the um strategies that we
use as a company
to kind of keep things moving in a
remote workforce
which obviously is a topic that is on
everyone's mind right now
since everything has gone virtual um
but uh i'd like to start with you know
we at wolf room have sort of been doing
remote work for
a little while like this isn't something
necessarily entirely new for us
so could you talk a little bit about
that like what kinds of things are we
already
have we already kind of been doing uh in
the past years
oh absolutely so we've always had some
flexibility
for certain positions so if
for instance developers that work on
code don't necessarily need to be in the
same room
in a collaborative environment so we've
we've allowed a lot of flexibility
for where people are located even if
people aren't located in the same place
all the time
we've we've let them work from home or
from whatever
you know place that works for them
depending on their their situation but
of course we've always maintained
an actual home office where those
collaborative meetings and
in the teams that need to come together
and see face to face
were were primarily stations um you know
march 12th came around and and everybody
went home
and now it's it was a struggle it was it
was now what do we do we don't
have these face-to-face meetings we
can't book a conference room and sit
around a table
and and work out whatever the the
current issue is at the time
so that that was the transition part
right right
yeah and and it's uh you know i can
speak to
being near the office it was always kind
of a
you know you can you can go in you can
work at home
most people would go into the office if
given the chance you know
um but now it's it's entirely remote uh
and that's that's definitely been a bit
of a transition for everyone i think
um but you know at the same time i think
there are
some advantages to working from remote
at least in some cases
uh although again this is sort of a bit
of a force situation but
could you speak to some of the some of
the things that you think are
good about people being able to work
from remote
absolutely so one of the most common
things that we've heard is
just the time saving you aren't
getting ready in the morning you aren't
doing a commute you don't have to drop
the kids off somewhere and then go pick
up something and then go into the office
your work time is you sit down at your
desk and that's your work time so
hopefully that um that would normally
free up a good amount of somebody's day
right uh where they aren't having to do
those things of course
we'll see how that plays out depending
on you know how how people are
getting their kids back to school or
daycare or all of the other things
that that we have to deal with right now
yeah yeah so there's all of that a lot
of those kinds of time-saving and
uh sort of energy-saving things in
theory um
even though it's it's a little bit up in
the air right now
um so what kinds of uh what kinds of
technology
do you find useful in terms of being
able to communicate being able to keep
up with everything
and uh sort of using your daily workflow
since since we've all gone remote
yeah so the the flexibility i think is
key because not the same thing works for
every single person
so i have teams that i meet with on zoom
where we do video because seeing
somebody's reaction
and seeing how passionate somebody is or
how upset somebody is
those are those are clues verbal clues
that are
really needed in some situations and
with some groups of people
um then of course there's there's the
everyday
decisions need to be made approvals need
to be given you have to look at this
thing real quick say yes or no
we use a lot of our instant messaging
platform for that
and that helps not have to track
somebody down
one of the things i was known for when
we were in the office is
if i needed something from you i was
going to show up at your door
i was going to be standing outside your
office like hello i need this thing
um and i can't do that anymore so now
it's well when do i pick up the phone
the phone feels so weird right now it's
just something that we haven't used very
much but now i'm starting to try to do a
voice thing if i can't get somebody on
zoom to go face to face
um or you know like i said the instant
message those are our primary methods of
communication right now right and of
course
you know the regular things um email and
uh
ticketing software things like that that
any any business would normally use
um but yeah it is it's almost kind of
surprising when you get used to
uh these zoom meetings and then um
suddenly you get into one where
everybody's actually
has their face showing and and you
realize that oh
yeah it's a lot easier to kind of read
people's reactions pick up on cues
um and i honestly i think it can make
meetings go faster sometimes because
there's
it's kind of easier to understand each
other a little bit better so
yeah i'm i'm definitely a fan of the uh
uh
getting face to face to the extent that
we can even though it's kind of tough
these days
um but of course that for for us it's
not just
um it's not just the everyday workflow
there's also
like events and and a lot of other
things that we've sort of
been having to rethink uh so you could
just talk talk
just a little bit about the events and
things
absolutely so um at the beginning you
know when we're like okay everybody's
doing this transition from home
we wanted to focus on making sure that
people had the tools that they needed
to make that transition so i know our
sales team had a big effort where they
were
basically saying if you need our cloud
or online technology
we'll give it to you for free here's
your transition
time to try to figure out how to make
this work from home
because not everybody had the background
that we had as a company to just
flip that switch so once
that immediate fire was was kind of
figured out we said what else are we
missing right now
and that that level of interaction and
engagement was something that we were
worried about losing
from our in-person events especially um
you know we have
our annual summer school and summer camp
which
we bring everybody to a college campus
and they stay in the dorms and
and you stay up late and you know drink
coffee and code and
together in an environment like that um
you know our wolfram u courses you know
a lot of them have always been online
but now that everybody's spending eight
hours or more a day
online did they really want to join
another
zoom session or get on the computer
again for another thing
so we came up with an idea of these
study groups
and what that was designed to do is
bring
people away from the online
technology you're being lectured to
you're staring at a screen getting stuff
delivered to you which everybody was now
quickly getting sick of doing sure so
the
the study groups the the concept behind
it was
bring people together let them turn on
their cameras let them ask
questions and really be engaged and work
on things together
and that was an environment that we
think really did take off we had a lot
of people that were really excited to be
able to have
that interaction that i think was
missing from their lives at that point
in time
yeah yeah i've heard a lot of good
things about the study groups and um
sort of the variety of people
that have showed up i think that's um to
me that
sort of speaks to a rich educational
environment like people
learning from people who are a little
bit different from them because you get
some of the uh you know older
professionals or
hobbyists or people who maybe have never
even touched on the subject
then you also have the the students and
the teachers and
you know it's uh i i i've heard that
lots of people have
have gained a lot from that so uh and i
know
so anytime you can join something when
you have a
a bright high school student teaching a
phd professor
yeah um or sharing that knowledge it's
it's it's a pretty special thing that's
pretty cool um and of course we've had
some uh some fun stuff going on
too um there's there are uh so many live
streams
these days that we're doing um so uh why
don't you want to
just give a little summary of uh what
kind of live streams we've got going on
oh so i'll talk about my favorite ones
right now so
um again back in in march uh april
uh steven was was again thinking like
okay we're in a position where we can
give
back at this point we have knowledge we
have resources
we have a this this environment that we
can
try to help people get through what's
currently going on in the world
and he started doing a q a session for
kids
and kids at heart every friday afternoon
where he joins the live stream and we
stream on twitch and youtube
simultaneously as well as this facebook
account
and just let people ask questions
anything from
how windmills work to if dogs could talk
you know how would we communicate with
them
some very very obscure things and some
some things that
i think even the professionals that that
tune in are like oh i didn't know that
yeah
yeah um and it's it's really accessible
and
and an environment that again just
encourages
this we're talking to other humans we're
not sitting
back getting delivered things like we're
watching tv but
but instead that that engagement that
that we are hoping for more and more
yeah and it's very uh it's very
impromptu which i appreciate
i like some of the uh stories that come
up and some of the sort of
you know side notes about things that
you know just little historical
footnotes that you might not have
realized
um goodness knows that steven's full of
them um
so um uh
yeah is there was there anything else i
guess that uh
you wanted to to talk about in terms of
you know remote work remote learning
anything that uh i i have forgotten
so i'll give you my favorite tagline so
anybody that's worked in any of my
groups in the last 10 years has heard me
say
we'll figure it out yes um
and and that's what we've done and i
think that's what
where we are in history with technology
and the technology stacks that we've
built and other people have built
really enables things that um that you
may not have dreamed were needed
at any point in time for instance high
fidelity
it's this spatial audio space and
one of the things that that we were
trying to think like
okay what's missing from this event now
that it has transitioned to virtual
and the number one thing is the hallway
chats the
i'm walking to get a glass of water
somebody's going somewhere else we bump
into each other and all of a sudden
there's this
this connection over an idea or um
a problem that we both want to solve and
and those don't happen virtually
because you've got 50 people in little
boxes
and everybody's on mute um and in
those those bump-ins just don't happen
so we
we use high fidelity i think first for
our company meeting
which we normally have every june and
everybody goes to the park across the
street from
from the headquarter building and and
you just get to have those
oh what are you working on these days
you know maybe our paths haven't crossed
in the last year because
you know we're working in in different
silos um
but the high fidelity space will has
allowed us to
bump into people and have little pockets
of conversations
without having to reach out like i
didn't know i wanted to talk to you but
now that i'm talking to you this is a
good thing
i wouldn't have scheduled it but i got
to bump into you
in in this space that that really
fosters
the the small individual group chat so
that is one thing that i thought i
thought was pretty neat that that we've
been trying to add into
more and more of our yeah yeah i know um
when they use the
high fidelity platform for the data
science boot camp
uh reception i ended up sort of getting
into a lot of conversations that i
wasn't really expecting to
um just because you know people might
approach you you might overhear
something
off to the side uh and that virtual uh
sound environment really gets me every
time you sort of sit and listen and
and it does kind of feel like you're
just in a room at a conference
or something you know it's just uh
having people talk around you
so um but i do i do like that uh we'll
figure it out
attitude i think that seems like a good
uh a good sort of ending note
um we whatever it is uh all the
complications that come with
being on lockdown and everyone going
remote we'll figure it out
so um thanks a lot for uh for talking
with me
anyone watching at home check out some
of the live streams
on our wolfram research youtube channel
join the next study group session
you can you can look out on wolfram.com
we'll have all the news
about all that stuff posted and keep an
eye out for
any other wolf from you or any other
events that we've got coming up
so uh thanks a lot danielle thank you
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more
on the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you